In the previous video about protein structure
We talked about different structure sequences
Start with the initial structure
- All we are talking about now is a review -
The primary structure is just a sequence of amino acids
But then we can start thinking
In how they are formed, by thinking about the secondary structure
Which are interactions
The infrastructure, we dig a little deeper
In the video induction, where we talked about
Some traditional secondary structures
We talked about parallel beta sheets
Here I have two basic structures
Directed in the same manner
Nitrogen, carbon alpha, carbon carbon
Now the side strings are drawn as general sets with the R code
What we have seen is that it is possible to have a hydrogen bond
Among these infrastructures, these are
Parallel plate
And if the two structures are mixed
These are towards nitrogen, carbon alpha, carbonyl carbon
These are carbon carbon, alpha carbon, and nitrogen
Our sheets become reversible parallel beta
Again, these are the interactions of the infrastructure.
Or we can have an alpha spiral like this
Where there are hydrogen bonds between
Different layers of the coil.
Then we get to the triangular structure,
When talking about the triangular structure
Side chain interactions are mentioned
And start thinking
What are these R groups and how
These groups affect the overall shape of the protein?
As an aid to think about it,
Some pictures are painted here below
Thus it is possible to imagine
To imagine this thread
The orange curve you painted here,
Suppose, for the sake of perception,
That this curve is the peptide series
I remind you of the review
We can think of the first level,
The primary structure, which is a
I have this amino acid, then this
Then this
This sequence is the primary structure
It is possible to have interactions within the infrastructure
Thus it is possible that these are here,
Parallel reverse beta plate
Here is where we have hydrogen bonds
I try to draw a dotted line but it is very small
Where we have hydrogen bonds
Here between these two basic structures
I did not draw the side chains here
We could have an alpha screw here.
Again, we have hydrogen bonds
Between the layers of the coil.
But let us now talk about the tripartite structure
Which relate to the side chains.
One example of a tripartite structure,
A number of side chains are drawn here.
This is from the amino acid "Valin", I did not draw the initial shape.
The infrastructure is on top here.
It is clear that nothing was painted according to the ladder
But the Palin side chain, its R range is
Hydrocarbons are pure, therefore they are water-resistant
So, one of the common interactions we can see
The side chains are that the strings are waterproof
Can not be outside
Of the protein molecule present in aqueous solution
Which is exposed to water.
But it is possible to rally towards the center,
Thus may affect the curvature
The polypeptide series
Or in the form of protein as a whole.
These, for example, may be water-threatening.
These here may be watery
Gather away from water.
I paint everything in two dimensions only,
But of course the proteins are present in three dimensions,
Making their forms interesting,
It is often difficult to catch up.
It is possible to have the amino acid Cyrine, for example
With a hydroxyl group in its side chain.
Since the hydroxyl group polarity,
We know that oxygen has an electrically negative much greater hydrogen,
Thus it will have a partial negative charge
This hydrogen will have a positive molecular charge
Which will allow for this side chain
To be more attractive with water, so it is possible to be oriented outward
To become in contact with the water solution.
Or can form hydrogen bonds
With other side chains.
So, let's say we have side strings like this.
And again, I do not draw it by the right standards.
The size of these side chains is larger than reality.
But we can have another side chain,
I will draw it this way,
We have another side chain that contains
At some point, you know, on many things
I will draw some points here.
This series contains many things, among them
Oxygen associated with hydrogen.
Linked to hydrogen.
There may be some hydrogen bonds
In this way, that will also help
Install the structure.
It is possible that we have cases
Side chains (ionic), Loaded side chains
You may have this sidebar here, for example,
Positive shipment.
And the structure of polypeptide
I will be adding such a fancy
It is possible that we have another side chain
Another side chain has
Total negative charge, therefore
These two chains will be attracted to each other,
And we will have a charismatic association (Ionian).
It is also possible to have covalent bonds between the side chains
This, for example, is a traditional covalent bond
It can be formed between two side chains of cystine,
Both contain sulfur.
When they leave
Each one of them
We are talking about cysteine, consisting of nitrogen
Carbon alpha, and carbonyl carbon
I'm trying to draw the cystine part
So, when this sulfur is not in any binary bond
With another sulfur it will form
Covalent bond with hydrogen.
However, when appropriate conditions exist,
Will form a covalent association with another sulfur.
In this case, this sulfur is in a side chain of another cysteine
Here, this line between them
Is a double-sulfur bond
Or what may also be known as a two-sulfur bridge.
If we can imagine, for example
Systeine ​​acid, this part of the infrastructure
This is cysteine, this is systeine
We can imagine that their two lateral chains can form
This two-sulfur link, which creates
A kind of networking between
This part of polypeptide.
I hope that gives you some kind of appreciation
For all the interactions that you can get
To give the protein a particular structure.
Last but not least, of course,
We have a quaternary structure, which is
How do we combine polypeptide chains together?
And all this series of videos,
Are just to give you some kind of appreciation,
For various forms and possible interactions,
For protein
Even if we know his peptide series,
This is what distinguishes proteins in their complexity
Beauty, and abilities to do
In all these functions: stimulating reactions (enzymes)
Signaling (hormones) and strengthening cytoskeleton
And help transport oxygen as it is
With hemoglobin protein.
This is a broad area of ​​research.
Even if we know the peptide series of protein, what is its shape?
On this basis,
How can we use it to think?
How to manipulate this protein in different ways
Or even other questions
It's really an attractive field of research!